recently a guy in Melbourne Florida was
arrested after he ran through town naked
while screaming he was Thor and trying
to have sex with a tree yes Florida man
high on Raqqa has secretary and calls
himself
Thor sure I was really I was like can
you imagine look at a sick pervert would
try to have sex with a tree in front of
a lot of people and suddenly the hell
was that
Alan why did you just cut to that guy
for no reason
sorry about that Conan just a camera
misses you it won't happen again
yeah it shouldn't happen again I'm sorry
that was that was terrible it was weird
it was weird and embarrassing our
apologies sir all right
anyway back to this story there's this
tree humping creep this absolute creep
[Applause]
oh yeah what are you doing I'm really
sorry Conan but while I was trying to
figure out what I did wrong I did it
again but we're good now we're good
no I wouldn't say we're good you really
embarrassed a member of our audience
twice I'm really sorry
get it together round ok will do all
right anyway thanks anyway
so talk about this story can you imagine
being so screwed up in the head you find
tree he's sexually arousing what the
hell you cut to him and this time I
heard sawing wood and moaning this is
really embarrassing I was building a
birdhouse for my niece and I must have
left my mic open
there's no way Alan you're building a
birdhouse for your needs during the show
guys cut to the booth see explain
anything
see birdhouse is he's building a bird
Danny now take his side look please Alan
stop it all right all right I'll finish
it during the commercial break yeah good
idea anyway
this total tree / stuff you're nuts oh
man
[Applause]
explain that out and explain it Coenen
you're not gonna believe this those
graph well dry out those graphics were
from a PSA reminding squirrels where to
store their nuts do we really need the
PSA for that a lot of dumb squirrels
okay let's just move on all right and
please no more mistakes absolutely ready
to go okay I just want to talk about
this guy okay it's a big news story who
claimed he was Thor and he had sex with
a tree I said no more mistakes that
wasn't a mistake hone and that was
product integration we do ads live in
the show now spunk in the trunk is a
product of course check it out keep your
trunk watertight every night with trunks
bunk I endorse this product and I have
sex a tree
[Applause]
why'd you put someone's mouth over that
audience member and had the mouth say I
have sex with trees I was wondering that
myself I don't know what's happening in
the booth I don't want to know you need
to stop it right now no more sound
effects no more birdhouses or squirrels
or spunk of the truck gas or anything
is that clear Alan you couldn't be more
clear boss you don't see any of that
stuff again
very good all right by the supreme power
of Almighty Odin I declare you for the
god of screwing trees
[Applause]
Sam's got
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
sexual
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please